Good morning, Rosita.
I see that you're having lunch.
Yeah, yeah, I'll wait.
Did you finish?
Do you know what day it is?
Well done!
And do you know why we are celebrating?
Well, Rosita, it's true that food and nutrition are important...
...but there is something else you should know.
Our continent is one of the richest regions on the planet.
Every year, millions of tons of wheat, corn, fruits, vegetables...
...and all kinds of meats and dairy products are produced.
This food is enough and even surpasses our nutritional needs...
...for every man, woman and child that lives in Latin America and the Caribbean.
And it is even enough to help feed many other countries.
Even though we have all these foods,...
...there are still millions of people...
...who daily wake up and go to sleep at night hungry.
There are many reasons that hunger exists.
But the most important one is that there are people...
...who do not have enough money to buy some.
But there's also the waste.
With all the food we throw away in the trash daily...
...we can feed all the people who are suffering from hunger.
Rosita, can I take your tray?
Very good, Rosita!
That's the attitude.